- [Narrator] Does
pineapple belong on pizza?
- No!
- Yeah.
- What?
- No way!
- What on Earth?
- OK, stop!
Sweden sees your pineapple
and raises you ...
banana on pizza, curry on
pizza, and kebab on pizza.
Seriously, Sweden?
(quirky music)
So, let's forget about pineapple,
because here in Sweden,
they have a completely
different take on pizza.
Here, it's a pizza topping free for all.
Mehmed has been cooking
pizzas for 25 years,
and he will tell you anything goes.
Things like banana.
(foreign language)
So, what do the Swedes eat in the summer?
I mean, who doesn't love a kebab?
So, Özen of La Babca
pizzeria, what's on your menu?
(foreign language)
Shrimp?
Oh, say it ain't so, Sweden!
Oh, there's more.
There's curry pizza, which is chicken,
banana, curry, and pineapple.
Or my favorite, tropicana:
ham, banana, and béarnaise.
Mm-mm.
Wait.
This isn't just a late night snack, is it?
(foreign language)
Now for the real question.
Why did Sweden reinvent
an already perfect food?
(foreign language)
And now the most
important part: the taste.
Mm!
This is really good!
(upbeat music)